what's going on everybody it's Warren
got an awesome video today teaming up
with these awesome guys right here Gregg
and John of the real rejects what's up
guys what's up I'm glad we finally get a
meet each we've met before
I haven't met you so this is an honor it
is not I'm really nervous
I would subscribe to you before you
subscribe I'm sure it was well you're
doing you're killing a person too we're
gonna keep reacting your videos and
before you know it we're all of our
video reactions you're just gonna the
Cosby reaction will be like her talking
dead was if you guys have not subscribed
to the real rejects be sure to do that
this is a two-part kind of collab we're
doing we're talking about Wolverine in
them see you in this video in the next
video on their channel we're going to be
talking about the Fantastic Four so be
sure to subscribe to them click the
notification bell so you know when our
next video comes out on their channel so
we're going to be talking about
Wolverine come into the MCU what are you
guys just initial reactions to that a
new Wolverine or even you know Hugh
Jackman John take it away my butt cheeks
clench because there's so much riding on
this decision that it almost feels
impossible to nail and it's gonna have
to be I think such an inspired choice
and I can't imagine actually what that
choice would be right now cuz especially
knowing Marvel I don't think they want
to go with somebody with a huge profile
at the same right yeah I'm excited for
the idea of getting a new origin movie
of Wolverine considering how terrible or
Wolverine was great trailer I wish there
was some talk of the MCU willing to do
some r-rated stuff because in x-men
comics and in Wolverines origins it's
pretty hard our and like a lot of
violence so I wish there was some
speculation or some rumor mill going
around that they are willing to do that
especially after Logan put in under 20th
century but yeah overall yeah of course
I'm excited it's freaking Wolverine man
so there's x-men and then there's
Wolverine mutants and x-men are the same
but Wolverine Wolverine yeah he is the
like he is like on the pedestal right
you really and you know he's the one
that they chose to your talk about that
first origin one you know like he's the
one did they chose to do that spin-off
with which was like horrible it's like
the CGI wasn't even done in all the
parts yeah like you wonder why and how
but you're right and John I'm with you
like I'm like oh man because you know I
talked about Wolverine a lot on this
channel and people are like no one can
replace you Jackman we did our poles
Hugh Jackman filled it up you guys had
to say don't say huge yeah so this oh
yeah absolutely
well I funny because like looking back
at Hugh Jackman when he first came on
for for the first x-men movie he wasn't
he wasn't huge he was like ski he was
like this first off he was he wasn't
popular secondly his body was like
reasonably fit it wasn't it wasn't what
we now associate Jackson's body to be
but I think this standard for
superheroes now whoever takes up the
mantle of Wolverine I think they're
gonna want a little bit more of an
accurate depiction and as great as Hugh
Jackman was there's still some things
that I think they could do that are a
little bit more comics accurate with the
physical appearance of him and maybe a
little bit yeah but also a little bit
more of an acrobatic guy to like a bull
drinkin like Flint stuff and the closes
we sounded like flipping off stuff was
x-men The Last Stand so I think it would
be cool to actually get some of that
enhanced powers all the x-men movies
with Hugh Jackman primarily leaned into
yes the personality the attitude but in
terms of powers it was like claws
healing powers and the occasional he can
smell stuff far away more to his powers
and abilities and fighting style than
just than just that
oh yeah completely and totally and you
know it's like you you want so badly a
Deadpool and Wolverine thing yeah
because the
you know they're over at Disney now and
it's just like you know there's a lot of
talk it's like well they're gonna kind
of keep Deadpool separate and keep him
rated R but maybe it'll come over and
it's just like you know what whatever
you do you're gonna keep that parade are
just there Wolverine in the movie with
them
yeah then we could get all that stuff in
there yeah I feel like that's the most
likely way Hugh Jackman will do it is if
there's some kind of cheeky way to work
it into Deadpool 3 or something like
that well I think it'll be a funny
Deadpool 3 post-credits eat a few
Jackman shows up I'm ready to do this
finally yeah like we already got a new
guy right because you know Deadpool to
the post-credits scene it's like the old
footage of him right Yeah right
Ryan real slow just cleaning up the
timeline that would be perfect something
like that like you said like oops I'm
ready to do this now and ran sleek but
we just filmed the movie yeah and it's
you know like you said it's like a big
deal coming into the MCU and I
petitioned for myself to play Hugh
Jackman if you're watching Kevin Feige I
can enjoy some scruff and if you want I
can get in super good shape I want a
cloven so I want to quote Warren he said
I want to play Hugh Jackman and that's
accurate that wasn't a mistake I can't
wait for that by Hugh Jackman Wolverine
I want to do I'm like in the press
interviews yeah so I want to play
Wolverine but there's a lot of people we
want to play Wolverine you all commented
and did polls on both of our channels so
let's see what you got this is going to
be the fan cast for the MCU for
Wolverine so we'll start with you guys
because you're the guest in my video
today who do you have coming in as the
least voted to play the new Wolverine
that would be other there's one lower at
9% for Shia I do not want him to do it
yeah Oh Shia LaBeouf is the lowest one
this is the first time I'm reading the
numbers so I'm reactors only a number
one that I can see here but the other
ones I'm looking at oh yeah Shia LaBeouf
we put them on our list and not sure
why that you suggested we sure may or
may not be my number one thing that's
fine some honorable mentions myself
yeah I mean I think Shia LaBeouf will be
very distracting i weirdly think he can
pull it off though but i think it would
be the collection buff is actually an
exceptionally talented actor yeah but at
the same time he occasionally does try
too hard like he's doing it but I'm
really aware he's really trying to do it
[Laughter]
it's all it's all drama all seriousness
and not a little bit of personality and
that's that's the wrong that's a proper
Shia LaBeouf can sometimes fall into
it's like he only goes for weight and
heaviness and buddy right when he's
really trying to deliver but I mean I
feel like he can do it but I can also
see him being probably one of the most
distracting picks especially with his
real-life personality yeah it's kind of
weird definitely I like him a lot but
he's done weird things right
yeah he's chilling you he was on hot
ones I loved fury was a great movie and
I actually like peanut butter Falcon
that small indie film that came out that
way yeah into a bunch of global theaters
I liked the movie a lot well honey boy
is also another one that everyone oh
yeah any boy but everyone raves about it
that it totally got gypped at the Oscars
I'm just quoting people who've seen it
I've never seen whose lowest on your
list lowest on my list is other
oh no wait it's tied it's tied 9% Daniel
Radcliffe you had Daniel Radcliffe yeah
he's a huge wide least I thought he was
really because he's short and I guess
he's been kind of scruffy and you know
people are saying like you got to pack
on weight off you take it right but like
I think it's primarily the shortness and
maybe people like oh yeah I'd love to
see Harry Potter like in the Marvel
Universe right yeah so but but you were
saying something before about
distracting and I think that would be
distracting I'd be like it's Harry
Potter it hold are good yeah it's not
well rayna's Harry Potter
you're a mutant Harry well have you
heard Daniel Radcliffe's American accent
it's I don't think he can do a badass
American accent probably does sound kind
of dewy be like Hugh Jackman's American
at all a huge Akron American accent
sound like Wolverine yeah yeah it sounds
more manly than all of our voices
combined yeah Daniel Radcliffe sounds
like James McAvoy and wanted at all
times
it's like dweeb ish nerdish kind of
voice right so I don't I don't think he
can I mean I know a Wolverines not wait
in the car no he's like Canadian right
yeah actually but he's never had a
Canadian accent he's got an American
yeah either way see if your life is a
bub like so I and it's funny cuz there's
like fan art of him as Wolverine like
there's a lot of different people who
want him to be Wolverine but again he's
not you know disrespected him I like
Harry Potter haven't seen much of his
other stuff but I don't see him as like
this manly tough Wolverine guy no but he
is exceptionally and surprisingly Harry
[Laughter]
fan I'm like he is a pretty hairy guy ha
yeah you need a razor so you know he
came in and lowest of my list and I
guess there's a real I guess there's a
reason for that right so but what about
you guys who's next for you I mean it is
other and do you want you should we list
off the other like the three most common
names from the other section yeah
actually one and I think these three are
better than Shia LaBeouf and Daniel
Radcliffe yeah we should have put one of
these guys on here first one would Scott
cam like we brought up earlier yeah
alright just because I don't know about
his acting chops yeah that's the debate
that was what I was
get the mutton chops off beards Jensen
Ackles from Supernatural play who plays
Dean I think he could definitely deliver
the performance but he's also played
tough brooding guy who's difficult to
work with for 15 years I think he would
be a fantastic Wolverine personally at
this point in time though I don't hey I
think it's it's also the profile thing
again but also I don't know if he's
gonna want to get that jacked at this
point as Jackie would need to any 6/1
you know and I think the other main pick
who I think it's perfect fit perfectly
fit for it but he's already got he's
already on the boys and he already
played red Carl wrote Karl Urban yeah
Karl Urban I think would be yeah I think
you would absolutely knock it out of the
park
right I'm like he's already done like
you know other roles it's very akin to a
Wolverine like character already right
and he's actually already in the MCU
that's right gonna be so much overlap
yeah but it's like they're taking Jim
machan and she was in Captain Marvel and
now she's riding Eternals as ser Z like
right right well I think it's different
to when like see Karl Urban's face in in
Ragnarok it's like it's still pretty
identifiable whereas Jeff it's gonna be
like doused and makeup and although
that's not as strong of a comparison is
because there's someone in Civil War who
also plays Maria and the rage series but
that's not it like she had just a
no-name character pretty much in Civil
War ID if you know her name awesome yeah
but yeah I mean I forgot I totally
forgot until you brought it up the car
urbanism thor ragnarok
that's right yeah disagree no I think
you would do an amazing job but the
thing that like you have to think about
is in John you said it like is he gonna
want to get that shredded but is he
gonna want to stay that shred
for like 10 to 15 years right because
you're not gonna bring Wolverine for
like one film right because it's
Wolverine yeah and and it sounds like
you know basically because we did we
reacted to the cosmic Wonders video and
based off of their - it's like if you're
gonna assign an MCU contract you're
gonna yeah you aren't given it's like 10
to 15 years and they're probably gonna
want not that Wolverine is young because
it's been around for deferred like
centuries
you're still gonna want a guy who's
definitely is like old to fast which is
that part of the trouble I've seen with
a lot of like the speculation lists
online and a lot of the pitches is yeah
a lot of these guys are in their 40s or
later and yeah to take up the mantle and
redefine Wolverine I think it could be
really cool if they did something more
akin to what DC's doing with their
one-off style movies but but yeah for
the MCU and we're gonna have him jumping
in and out of a bunch of stuff I think
they're gonna want somebody on not the
Peter Parker young side but yeah like
late twenties yeah yeah that's a good
call what's your second one other as
well there's tide you said was tide so
Taron Egerton oh okay Taron Egerton ii
this is one that I've heard a lot and I
could see it I actually think that he's
done a really good job he's got range
he definitely has Reyes because I've
seen him in Kingsman and then I've seen
it in or Rocket Man Rocket Man that's
really good what though he was in one
with you Eddie in the eighth Eddie Eddie
Eddie the ego that was a great movie
plus he was with Hugh Jackman so it's
kind of yeah but that was a great movie
and like to be able to play the role in
Kingsman and then Eddie the Eagle it's
like okay you've got range and you know
you could pack on some weight you're not
insanely tall right I could see it what
do you think maybe that's what Hugh
Jackman has been talking to Kevin Feige
about maybe he's just in there being in
his corner like come on right you got a
cost Terry in this mate I think I think
Taron Egerton is
surprisingly still underrated by
whatever praise he got with Rocketman
and he did win a Golden Globe I I still
don't think he has gotten the credit he
truthfully deserves I think he did I
think he most definitely could pull it
off actually yeah he's a fantastic actor
yes he is in space it he's insanely
badass and kings yeah it's all he's also
be this could be the movie where he
breaks the leo barrier and like finally
gets from boyish charming right rugged
man you know right all fairness I gotta
see him playing now like a Human Torch
character to advertising sales promotion
yeah I think he's a pretty that's a
solid pick to me yeah he's actually our
third pick 40% second second second toss
a coin to your Witcher freak app old
Superman himself is my second as well so
oh really and I know I first said the
same but he's our second as well oh
really oh you just got cut in half yeah
so you go first I don't want to go first
because I apparently I've been
pronouncing his name wrong it's Henry
Cavill there's cavil cavil I've said
contains all my videos and I've seen
comments or like you can't even say his
name right I'm like I thought that's how
it was said how about we call HC how
about Adele Tosh so he besides the fact
36 to what do you guys think about him
well you know I haven't finished the
wisher and yes he's got the build he's
reasonably charismatic I enjoy watching
him I think the thing that makes
Wolverine so special though is how much
depth is in that character and how much
of a tortured
soeul he really loves ya like he's got
so much aybe that he's just forgotten
about and be whenever he remembers it
just like destroys him internally mm-hmm
and what show was Couvillion but show
what she was Rome was it I I haven't
seen whatever show he was on some maybe
the one before which ER before Superman
and all that night I just don't
III haven't yet and maybe this is just
on my end of not having seen all of his
work I haven't yet seen him in something
that brings such a great level of depth
and he's gotten a lot of big roles it's
got some pretty sizable roles already
when the trailer was cooler for him than
the movie and a lot of yeah and I hear I
hear he is amazing in Witcher I haven't
finished a series yet but I haven't
gotten to anything at Witcher were I'm
like yeah he's he's the best round but I
sure he's got the build he is tall which
is actually against the Wolverine
description but and I get why people
would want him I just
I'm not gravitated towards it just
because I don't I haven't seen anything
that brings that level of death like if
you're gonna cast someone post Hugh
Jackman you need beyond body type right
look you know you need a hell of a actor
a hell of a performer when I think
there's also something that happens now
especially with actors like Henry Cavill
where they reach this big profile but
they're also like trying to plug him
into the right role that really makes
everybody loved him and Greg you know
really expands his career and all that
and I don't think they've quite found it
yet maybe The Witcher will make that
difference but that's I think back to
Bowfinger
that a whole conversation they have
about do I have it and there's like an
if factor that I just that I can't
describe that yeah I just haven't really
been moved to that point to be like yeah
this guy can take on you know the
tortured past and the Menace and all
that stuff yeah what about you what are
your thoughts
um I think and I really do like him as
an actor I agree with you Greg and I
agree with you John I think I haven't
seen the depth and I haven't seen
everything he's in right so I guess I'm
not one to judge but from what I've seen
I haven't seen the depth and I don't
think he has found it yet but I think
the talk right now is hey Superman's
coming from DC to possibly play
Wolverine but that's actually why I
think Marvel won't do it if he's so
dismissive
they don't want Superman right it's like
we can't because he's Superman despite
and and you know they came out and they
were like there's no real rivalry
between DC and Marvel because James Gunn
you know he's doing guardians 3 he did
guardians 1 & 2 and he's doing Suicide
Squad now and he came out said he's like
there's no rivalry between them
whatsoever no Marvel got jealous that he
was seeing DC and we're like no cheater
I won't read your tweets again I know
right so the rivalries between the fans
right because there's a fine line
between some fans but to me I would see
Superman and I would see the mustache
the whole entire time yeah horrible CGI
and that one in in the movie for him to
get rid of the mustache was so funny but
that's what I would see so look and I
think there's a certain amount of of his
like Superman not being the beloved one
that kind of informs his status right
now like I feel like that's part of why
a lot of fans have that passion for him
is because a lot of people see those
movies is being kind of wronged by
critics and other fans and so some
people vehemently love his Superman and
I think want him to explode kind of well
off of that yeah he still has campaign
to get Manistee like as much as he yeah
he's talked about you know the issues
with Justice League and he wants to move
past this whole Snyder cut talk he has
pushed for still wanting to do Man of
Steel - and honestly I would much rather
see him do that because as weird as the
moustache was at times in Justice League
I still thought that by the finale of
Justice League he was really
morphing into the charismatic Superman
that we all kind of wanted right and I
would love to see him really knock it
out the park with a proper man with it
with a good Man of Steel part two and
like they talked about getting Matthew
Vaughn the director of the Kingsmen
movies and kick ass and x-men first
class don't be a dumbass getting getting
him to do that I feel like that would be
a really great fit to with his with his
kind of comedic sensibilities that
Matthew Vaughn has his action style yeah
and Henry Cavill was or was also in was
that guy ritchie movie Oh the gentleman
the one with Armie Hammer yeah I know it
too I can't remember
oh man for Mom coal there yeah like he
was really charming in that one of his
not Guy Ritchie The Man From UNCLE and
so yeah that's that's more of where I
want to see him do it he's already got
brooding badass woods with the first Man
of Steel movie yes and he's got The
Witcher I feel like yeah that role is
not to drawn to it that that pick
personally I wouldn't be enthused yeah
they're good and that's you know and
that's what it comes down to I think I
think Marvel takes that into account
yeah they're great with their casting
yeah I generally trust whoever they cast
yeah and they seem like they want to
start the right kind of conversation
where they want intrigue over who the
person is and what their talent will
bring to the universe just as much yeah
the only too obvious picks I think
Marvel has ever done with casting was
Chris Evans as Captain America like
you're like yeah that sounds right right
and Jon Bernthal and Punisher those are
the only two where I'm like yeah yeah
that's about it some people have been
pitching heavily for Jon Bernthal and
I'm like but he's I I see so much of the
Punisher because of his love and
dedication of that character that he
even outside the show is expressed the
show
all right all the radius characters
making the juggernaut yes
everything just you can do all of it
right any CGI helmet no big deal yeah
you know but you make a good point
because people actually love him as The
Punisher like love him as the Punisher
and I don't think they'd like I think
they would rather him come into the MCU
as The Punisher still didn't play
Wolverine yeah anyway we should move
should talk about our number one pick
number one pink it's got to be the same
I mean I see it right here it's the same
boundaries what's your percentage so my
percentage for counter is 56% Wow we're
at 45% yeah so basically half you know
give her yeah if you average them
together yeah what do you guys think
this is a meme aye-aye-aye
okay I got it I got a couple answers
here I I really love Keanu Reeves I do
too I love him in the right roles like
neo or John wick mm-hmm I also love him
when he's not cast properly like bad
Keanu Reeves performance is a fun I like
British accent I like both but at the
end of the day and people will probably
disagree with me on this I think here on
Reeves as much of a brooding brawny kind
of character that Wolverine is and the
loner ristic kind of personality I just
don't think he honor Reeves has truly
has B when he when he's quiet he's
amazing and a few little lines of
dialogue with that little voice of his
primal yeah that's awesome but what and
I think when you give him a lot of die
just imagine the first time the claws
come out I think as he gets older I feel
like he gets better as an actor I'm sure
he yeah he's I think like he's at the
best of his acting capabilities and ever
knock knock man
hey Roz knock knock yes I think um but I
still don't feel like let's I think if
you're gonna talk about the acting
capabilities of Hugh Jackman and not
that it's gonna be the same right but I
still think you're gonna need an actor
who at least matches the the caliber of
acting talent or surpasses and I don't
think he honor Reeves has that hmm
I don't think apparently towards Hugh
Jackman I love him I really thought I
really do but I I don't think that and
also yeah I like he's he's already neo
and John wick the other thing too is as
long as I know they want to keep John
wick movies going just forever but I
think that they are starting to wear and
tear on his body to a point that I don't
think yeah we're gonna get that 10 to 15
years of roided-out hitting on you yeah
I don't think that's gonna work
he's already like I mean he's John wick
he's great at playing like the quiet
tortured soul yeah but I think ballistic
rager that we associate with Wolverine
mm-hmm I'm not sure I'm just not fully
confident that he would I just and I
also think we would see Keanu Reeves I
think that's a big part of why we love
John wick is because we still see we'd
love with you don't only see John wick
we still see Keanu it's not we love it
it's not just who killed your puppy it's
who hurt keen on him yeah yeah well I
think there's layers he can definitely
nail I think there's a plenty of
emotional layers he can nail I'm talking
nothing in the full spectrum and and I
like I get why he's the most voted at
the same time I don't think he's the
right pick for it yeah fair enough
where Warren says go to hell don't react
to my stuff anymore
block them all that sighs um IBG how do
you not love Keanu Reeves right I mean
he's Keanu Reeves and it's some sure
someone I found away don't hurt Keanu
like yeah leave him alone but we would
see Keanu we would see John wick and we
would see neo and especially John wick
for and matrix for coming out in the
same day yeah that's right miss that
news
so you know the talk right now is is
that he's a met with you
Marvel and Kevin Feige said we talked
ken Reeves about every movie we do to
find a role for him and we just haven't
got a role for him yet and you know and
that and he said they did the same thing
with Jake Gyllenhaal
they met with him for many many movies
until they found Mysterio and they were
like this is it this is the movie and he
was cast the same things happening for
you Keanu right now now they may not
find the perfect role for him but they
may decide it could be Wolverine but I
don't think it will
John there's a terrific troll right
exactly I don't think I think you would
make an excellent Silver Surfer I think
he has the perfect demeanor for that but
we'll talk to him oh yeah I think he
could do the intensity because I see
John wick and I'm like just give him
claws instead of guns and he does
hand-to-hand combat a lot too he has the
emotional depth to be that tortured so
like you talked about but I can't I just
don't see it yeah cuz I see neo I see
John wick I see Keanu yeah and I do
think with this and we'll talk about our
personal pics right after this I do
think it kind of needs to be someone who
isn't really come up yet because that's
what Hugh Jackman wasn't really huge
Jackman like you said in the beginning
he wasn't that big and I actually saw
Hugh Jackman's great a shipment or live
last year and he said during the show
he's like I almost quit and I thought I
was gonna get fired but I founded my
role and it was perfect and he wasn't
that big then so I think that almost
needs to be kind of the same thing I
actually think that we'll jump into it
now out of all the picks that I've heard
probably Taron Egerton would be out of
everything we've heard would be the top
pick yeah but I would say out of the out
of the picks from the fans and the ones
we put out for the fans to vote on
mm-hmm I would I would agree with you
there yeah we're definitely had a third
one on to that pile were unanimous who
are your personal now Shia LaBeouf I'm
changing it personal pick my personal
pick is not in the category that you're
talking about because I because I it's
weird like I I agree with you I feel
hardly a guru do that it should be an
actor like that but no one came to mind
for me I couldn't come up with one and
that's part of the thing of auditioning
and stuff as you find that unknown and
they read it because I don't know who
the unknown is because I don't audition
people so I went with someone who I
still who I feel like is like he's
gotten in in smaller films he's gotten
so much praise and he's got a wide range
of acting talent but he just his bigger
movies and he's in an x-men movie his
bigger movies he just hasn't really got
in the the proper role or the right
script for the character that he's been
for the card he's been dealt and it
would actually be Oscar Isaac I would
say Oscar Isaac like his I first saw him
in the movie Drive and and like yeah
then I remember watching force awakens
and I had no idea that those were the
same guys Mach you know with Mike's a
shaved head ex machina like he has a
shaved head and beard in drive as well
but it's like two completely different
characters you could do different time
periods and then I think I think he has
the body type that could definitely do
it he's definitely got the emotional
depth
yeah and gryzzl you want you know yeah
and I think he's got the the kind of
snarky sarcasm
I think it does to like who doesn't talk
about he's he's got that sarcasm too in
a way that he's able to throw out so
naturally and it doesn't
like he's putting it on in like an epic
team and I don't think Poe Dameron the
character was written all that well but
I think one thing we can agree on is
that Oscar Isaac elevated that role owed
and and and I think that's what you need
is an actor with the kind of charisma
and yet the same level of depth and
Oscar Isaac I think is it's like most
people know the name Oscar Isaac like
most people know the name Oscar Isaac
for others association of Poe Dameron
but Poe Dameron isn't exactly one of the
top 5 greatest stars no Lewin Davis yeah
so he's not he's not quite there and
they even tried giving him more screen
time and Rises Skywalker and he was
funny in that but they were essentially
just try making him han Solo and I and I
think with like Apocalypse
he wasn't just wasn't a well-written
character it's just generic and covered
in makeup so if you didn't tell me it
was Oscar Isaac I might never know what
yeah but yeah but if you watch other
Oscar Isaac performances like all across
the board
he's an insanely incredible actor he's
amazing he can he can do every single
quality that is associated with
Wolverine and I think he has I think
it's just the right look to you know
yeah so I would petition for him but
yeah I still agree with you that it
should be someone who's unknown but if I
if it's not going to be I would say
Oscar Isaac and he's not the MCU yet so
I'm gonna I'm gonna go ahead no I was
just gonna say well he's not exactly
huge exactly took him there but still
it's not like Oh everyone's talking
about you know no one everyone's not
talking about him so he's still I think
in that class where you could do it yeah
so we're gonna put him on this poll
because he's like my top pick yeah
people who and actors who are known yeah
exactly he's got the caliber stuff like
he started out in like high-caliber film
films and yeah has been has had smart
people enough to get him into some
high-profile stuff yet he just hasn't he
hasn't wrecked any of that and so it
seems like that would be one of those
cases where yeah this guy I think does
deserve that shot to run owned and
centralize a roll I don't know exactly
how old he is I feel like he's pushing
the limit a little bit in that sense but
I could see him you know edging it out
and yeah there's also I was just amused
that online there was a good strong
following for Danny DeVito that was my
number one pick people want to jump in
but I'm gonna I'm gonna throw out a hot
a potentially hot take because I think
that if you if you wanted I could
imagine a time line on which Liam
Hemsworth undergoes some kind of Ryan
Reynolds Ian type acting overhaul where
he like really develops his chops and
then really bulks up and kind of
redefined his image gonna fit a long
time since I've thought about that guy
and when I saw him on somebody else's
list I was like what and then I looked
at the picture and I was like if he had
the chops he could maybe do it so like I
don't see it happening but you know
Chris Hemsworth's already the universe
of all the Scott Eastwood types I guess
he was my favorite yeah yeah and that
was another one that you know a lot of
people have mentioned before Scott
Eastwood a lot of people want a guy
that's shorter though you know what I
mean they like really want the Wolverine
Tom Cruise Oscar Isaacs I yeah he might
ease probably closer to it I'm him and
Taryn my number one as a joke was gonna
be Danny DeVito cuz there's been so many
memes about it yeah this is so funny to
watch it's just like it just so I could
just imagine him back in the day though
if he got fit you know what
- Wolverines we're gonna do we're gonna
do it again we're gonna do Danny DeVito
and Arnold Schwarzenegger well we'll
have this junior Burt with Wolverine or
you could do some kind of time-travel
thing where Danny DeVito's is old man
Wolverine there we go in a different
totally different time yeah hey
alternate universes come into them see
you anything is possible right sure any
of the memes are actually possible now
as well too with the multiverse coming
to them's you so well alright those are
our picks I think they're solid picks
Oscar Isaac I like it I think that's a
pretty good one and you know what John
if you're you made a pretty good point
if liam hemsworth could do it i mean
let's be honest he has the connections
right he does so yeah it looks too much
like Chris Hemsworth though see when I
saw the picture and he was beardy I was
like okay it looks kind of different
from Chris but maybe I need to look at
them side-by-side because you have to
wonder like but what more will do that
like do the cast if he got like wide
thick you know I know on the DC shows
Stephen Amell and Robbie Amell play two
different like Stephen Amell was arrow
and then Robbie Amell was oh he was like
he was like on fly he's like crossover
and all of them I forget which one he
was it's different they're both like
kind of known I haven't thought about
him in a while I don't remember anything
he's been in a while either but if he
you know like you said it got the chops
for it that would be a pretty decent
choice as well I think out of everything
that we've talked about today I got to
go with you there Oscar or Taryn I think
my top picks because I think they're
both pretty well known but not like over
the top yet it could be the film that
and you know if they were cast for this
part it could be the character to take
them there yeah yeah alright way to pick
up your own names that's good this has
been our Wolverine fan cast and thank
you all so much for helping us with this
these are basically your choices Keanu
Reeves of course coming in at number one
but still let us know who you think
after this conversation should play
Wolverine and again don't forget to
subscribe to real rejects we'll be doing
a video for the Fantastic Four on their
channel very very soon we love your
videos remember us when you get to the
top yeah
and subscriber count' and then you're
gonna they're gonna like I said we don't
matter
please collab with those used to be cool
and everything like what - like down
there rejects it wait till I'm cast as
Wolverine right and then yeah and huge
and in the biopic a huge idea one I want
to be Hugh Jackman who doesn't want to
be Hugh Jackman though yeah
but they guys so much for watching this
video be sure to subscribe to them and
we'll be coming out with the Fantastic
Four video really soon so you guys see
you guys wonder it out